c'est sympa la voilà enfin semblant de
bosser meilleur que toi ce petit jeu là
haut tu vas te casser oui c'est moi le
plus consciencieux c'est moi le plus
travailleur c'est moi qui pars dernier
ça s'est fait appeler papier papier
papier sur place et je recommence
[Rires]
le fils de vous fait pas voulu de
madame vous êtes pas vous n'êtes pas de
but non je parle à lui comme tu sais que
put ces faits mineurs mais je peux très
bien pu dire connard non en fait n'était
pas ça oui bonsoir en fin d'année bien
nos gants non non je veux pas le grand
nom c'est dégueu le jeu le camp non je
veux pas le gant à la personne du ménage
bien joué et d'eric ok très bien très
bien pas faites comme chez vous un peu
comme chez moi
spi ça si je parle pas la fois je lui
parle
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais de quoi je peux lui parler je ne
sais pas comment c'est une conversation
non rien
enfin
la météo non c'est ta famille oui nantes
est identiquement pour continuer
continuer si j'ai les racines ouvrières
je crois pas comme l'autre connard là
qui pètent dans la soie la demande du
même sang et moi même celui de terrain
les mains dans le cambouis voilà on est
des petites jambes c'est un beau métier
pour fait non je trouve sa noble car
c'est un petit peu un artisan la
propreté
l'agent d'entretien
voilà ça c'est du parler vrai c'est fou
le bien que ça fait moi je vous tire mon
chapeau je pourrais pas faire ce que
vous ce que vous faites je sais ce que
tu espères les vitres moi aussi j'ai les
tests j'ai mm mais c'est pas une passion
les vitres bah oui quand je dis ça
surtout pour les produits chimiques
parce que moi je suis hypersensible
je sais pas ce qu'ils foutent de danse
et cancéreuses chiites ce truc vous
nettoyer mon buggy comme ça oui c'est
notamment tous les jours mais je vais
crever j'imaginais que vous mettiez au
lave-vaisselle - non mais tu là elle me
tue à petit feu
oh oh pis gagner et ouais c'est moi qui
bosse le plus connard allez casse aussi
vous faites là vous mettez tous dans la
même poubelle
oui non mais c'est pas possible madame
je mets en place un super plan de
recyclage dans la boîte si j'ai quelques
arbres et impôts faire 60 bureaux alors
l'écrire et puis moi j'ai que ces
poubelles mal à quand donc la fin du
monde la fonte des glaces si c'est pas
les tâches c'est pas des matériels
pourrait coûter moi je me fous de tout
là ça va pas du tout j'appelle le
prestataire demain ils vont m'entendre
bien sûr oui quoi sert ou les drh oui
c'est moi le drh et si on est très très
bas p ah oui alors ça il faut voir avec
votre employeur
prestataire de services d'accor
messieurs oui enfin vos pions aux envois
à l'autre bout du monde
oui mais le temps les transports n'ai
jamais payé dette d'accor pardon et moi
je paye une fortune le prestataire de
service justement pour ne pas avoir à
gérer ce genre de conversation voyez ce
que je veux dire ah oui oui et nous
alors oui et les noirs ou les malades
stop
vous savez quoi tout ce qui reste à
terre si avec le drh qu'il faut voir ça
oui c'est bien mais non aux
[Musique]
[Rires]